adam wainwright is
he'll get the first start of this second
half and he is seven and five with a
three five eight era yeah and looking
forward for adam wainwright to pick up
where he left off the hyundai pitch
arsenal for adam wainwright you know
what he's got he's got the fourth seam
the two seam he uses that cutter
effectively into lefties change up he
sprinkles in and old uncle charlie
and the 3-2
swung on and missed and a strikeout to
start the game ninth season in his
career with a hundred k's only bob
gibson with more for st louis 14.
swinging a miss back to back kays
and the o2 pitch
he strikes out the side in the first
inning that's how we want to see the
second half begin
there's a look at logan webb pressed
into action tonight
we thought gosman was going but you know
what sometimes you have your best
outings
when you're not really ready for it so i
expect good things out of logan webb you
see the numbers on the year
a chain jump and what a beautiful
sequence for logan webb
to start his night
colt schmidt on the ground to third
wilmer flores
throws him out two down
3-2
chops that one to first lamont wade will
take it himself and that's a very strong
first inning for logan webb
on we go to the second with dickerson
and crawford coming up no score in st
louis
here's a pop-up that's on the infield
goes into shallow center field let's see
if the center field is going to take it
he will
and the 2-2 pitch
popped up
molina
calling for it has it
two-way
that is lifted in the air
right-center vader back and has it
molina a chance to make a little history
here tonight skip the all-star game in
order to rest but he will tie gary
carter fourth all-time in games caught
2050
as he has appeared behind the dish
tonight
backhanded the young
long throw the stretch by goldie nice
play on both ends
so first time through the lineup four
strikeouts one hit allowed and no walks
[Applause]
0-2 pitch
coronado
man is he fun to watch is something else
to watch nolan oronato dylan carlson the
most games played by a rookie in
cardinals history before the all-star
break
one two
on the ground to shortstop
crawford throws out carlson bader did
break for third he's there with two down
and baiter to third brings in paul
goldsmith
chopped up the middle solano settles
throws and makes the play the top of the
order mike kustramski
he pulled that one toward the right
field corner and it is gone a live drive
home run straight down the line for mike
gustrebski home run number 13 and that's
the first run of the night
inside corner struck him out
tommy edmond cardinals with a runner in
scoring position nolan arnado
a little flare out to shallow left this
ball will drop here comes aronado
he will score and the game is tied at
one
the 1-0 the young base hit into right
edmond to second
now to third the throw
not in time runners at the corners for
st louis
and the base is loaded now for adam
wainwright he was yet to pick up a run
batted in this season
the one-two he did chase strike three
swinging on the slider the first two
have now reached for the giants here in
the fifth inning kurt casalli now the
batter
swing and a miss he struck him out
strikeout number seven
that's a big one there
curveball fly ball center field that's a
can of corn
cardinal centerfielder is there and he
makes the catch so two down
and the lot way junior stands in
wade swings in that curve and rips it to
right field over the head of
carlson and out of the ballpark a
three-run homer for lamont wade junior
the giants do take the lead back with
the big fly his eighth of the year it's
four to one
o'neal base hit into left center
goldie
around second to third and the tying run
will come to the plate
and the time run comes to the plate
yadier molina
that fastball hit to right ustremski is
there though to make the catch out
number three crawford tonight has popped
out to the catcher has flied to center
and crawford hits it in the air to
center backing up vader he'll make the
catch the 01.
in the air towards right field
backing up
carlson and he has it
stay sharp like it has been
edmond flips a little slider to left
dickerson is there to make the catch
[Applause]
off the end of the bat into shallow
right racing in yastrimsky won't get
there drops in for a hit
carpenter on the season as a pincher
that's 5-32 he has two home runs driven
in eight
carpenter on the first pitch bounces it
to first wade has it goes to second a
wide throw but crawford keeps his foot
on the bag and out there is bader
[Applause]
got him swinging harley and garcia great
job out of the pen for the giants
and now mike yostrimsky steps in
jastremski with a whole home run this
evening
on the first pitch yostremski hits a
high fly ball deep right field carlson's
back he's at the track he leaps it's
gone mikey strebski has done it again
a three-run homer here in the seventh
his second home run of the night and the
giants have opened up a 7-1 lead
lifted in the air left center
goodbye
paul goldsmith
in 11 games with a hit in a row that'll
bring up yaddio molina molina oh for
three on this evening 3-2 pitch
base heading to right
fifth all-time by himself in cardinals
history hit number
2065 for yadier molino molina at third
edmond is at second and paul deyoung is
at first all right well here comes
harrison bader
fastball right on the outside corner
strike three call
ripped into right field and that's a
base hit for granted crawford
[Applause]
but whatever was going on didn't impact
his swing
he's walking off fine but he just
there was a swing he grabbed that left
lower hamstring
0-2 on the ground to short estrada
throws out tommy edmond and the ball
game is over